And with that, ladies and gentlemen,
please put your hands together and
welcome our host to present today.
Please
welcome Mike Delto.
Thanks, Scott. They uh forget me set up
there. Had a little minor crash of the
system. Um everyone, today's my name is
Michael Valtos. I'm the founder of
trader at orderflows.com. And today I'm
going to talk about the three keys to
orderflow trading that will improve your
trading results. I mean, you know, as
traders, you all want to keep improving
your game, you know? I mean, like an
athlete, you know, you just don't go
out, you know, NFL player just doesn't
go out every Sunday and throw the ball,
you know. He's always trying to improve
his game during the week, you know, and
as a trader, you should be looking to do
the same. So, just, you know, before we
get started, you know, a quick
disclaimer, this is for
educationalformational purposes only.
Should not be considered a solicitation,
a buy or sell a futures contract or make
any other type of investment decision.
You know, futures trading contains
substantial risk and not for every
investor. Basically, you know, don't
trade with money that you got to live
on, you know, money that needs to pay
the bills. um you know risk capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk capital
should consider trading. So you're in
the right place today. You know if you
want to know more about orderflow and
how it can help you make more profits in
trading by correcting you know common
trading mistakes. You know maybe you're
new to trading and want to get off to a
quick solid start without wasting a lot
of
time and money learning how to trade. or
you know maybe you tried
orderflow and feel that's the right way
to trade but you just can't put your
finger on it to make it work for you
you're in the right place as I'll
definitely show you how orderflow can
help you become a better trader so you
know it doesn't matter if you're new to
trading or whether you've been trading
for years you know there's something in
order flow for everybody and you know
I'm not going to spend a lot of time
explaining what order flow is you know
most people are already familiar with
orderflow this is an orderflows chart
you know I have a software it's an
orderflows trader software ware and you
know it it's a takes a basic volume
footprint chart and adds more to it. You
know part of the problem with a lot of
software out there is you get it but you
don't know how to read it. I mean you
know what good is trading with orderflow
if you don't know what to look for and
you know one of the things that I do at
orderflows.com is you know help people
learn how to trade with orderflow.
I mean, you know, it's like you have a,
you know, high performance sports car,
but if you're just going to drive it
normally, you know, what's the
point? So, what you're going to learn
today by hanging around you, I'm going
to talk about market imbalances, you
know, which allow you to see what's
happening in the price action. You know,
if a big buyer scooped up a big offer
or, you know, a big seller came in and
sold into what was a big bid, you know,
what's that information worth to you?
You know, how can you use that in your
trading? And you hear a lot of people
talking about price action. Oh, you got
I trade with price action, but they
never really get into it. You know, you
don't understand, you know, really what
price action is, you know, but seeing
market imbalances will really turn that
light bulb on. And, you know, the next
thing I get into is, you know, I got to
one of the problems that most new
traders have is they treat every bar,
every price in a bar the same, you know,
but not every price is the same. You
know, some price levels in a bar have
light volume. Some have average volume.
And there's going to be one price level
in a bar that has the most volume. That
price level with most volume is called
the point of control. Also known as the
P. So if you hear me refer to PC, I'm
referring to point of control. And
lastly, the last thing I want to talk
about
is delta. You know, Delta will help you
learn to decide, you know, if buyers or
sellers are in control and more
importantly how to determine what their
strength is. And it's very valuable
information to the trader. It's
basically it's a net difference between
aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers. You know, every time you market
goes up, you you hear people say, "Well,
there's more buyers than sellers." I
mean, that's not, you know, a not
accurate depiction. What you have is
more aggressive buyers than than
sellers.
And if you hang around till the end, I
got a few free things for you that you
can
download. Like I said, you know, I I
know a lot of people already use
Orderflow or have tried Orderflow. And
I've got two things for you at the end.
One is a PDF guide that I've written
with uh my hidden what I call hidden
trading opportunities in order flow. So,
you know, if if you're interested to
trade order flow and want to know how to
use it, that guide, you know, will give
you three trade setups that you could
use right away. And the other the other
thing that I'm giving away is this free
indicator that I created called the
Delta Surge. And you know what it does
is it picks up increased buying and
selling, you know, aggressive buying and
selling and and gives you nice signals,
you know, on on markets that are, you
know, that are trending. So, you know,
who am I? You know, why you should
listen to
me? You know, for those that don't know
me, um, you know, I've been trading, you
know, for over 20 years. And, you know,
trading on the institutional side, I
don't want to say at the highest level,
but at a very high level. I started at
the C on the CME floor with Dean Widow
Reynolds back in
1994 when Globex started taking off. You
know, GloveX was CME's electronic
trading system. I moved off the floor to
the upstairs trading desk. Then
eventually I moved to EDF man you know
the big grain it's not grain but sugar
and softs commodity trader in 98 I
joined commerce bank on their upstairs
trading desk and you know I became a
licensed URX trader you know for those
that are you know European and you know
that understand how URX used to work you
used to to trade on URX terminals you
had to have a a a URX license and
there's this big long exam to go through
and you know it wasn't easy But uh I
managed to pass it. Daniel in 2002 I
joined Cargill. Cargill is the big grain
trading company in the United States.
They they trade they export about 25% of
corn from the United States. You know
that's how big they are. They provide
McDonald's with all their cooking oil
and they they trade a lot. They've been
around for 150 years. So they know what
they're doing when it comes to trading.
2004 I set up Cargill's futures trading
desk in Singapore. 2006 I joined JP
Morgan as a vice president on the
futures trading desk and I left JP
Morgan in 2013 and joined order flows
sorry I started order flows after I left
JP Morgan now you got to ask yourself
why do I talk about that you know I'm
not talking about it to be you know to
brag or anything not not at all but you
know if ask yourself right if you want
to have surgery done who do you want to
who do you want to operate on you
someone that has 20 years of experience
or someone just out of medical school
with you know little real life
experience and lots of experience you
know practicing on cadaavvers you know
which to me is the equivalent of sim
trading in the market you know I have
that experience you know I'm not shy
about it I don't hide from it but at the
same time you know I want you to know
that you know what I have to say you
know comes from real life experience you
know there there's not a lot of people
that you know that are trying to teach
people how to trade that are working
with new traders that have that you know
solid institutional
experience you know so just really quick
you know why did I start order flows you
know said I left JP Morgan in 2013 I
started order flows in 2015 you know but
I was trading for myself and when I'm
trading for yourself you know oftentimes
you you buy yourself and you know you
don't have that interaction I didn't
have that interaction anymore that I
used to have before you know but so I
started order flows so I could have
interaction with traders Again now early
in my career I was very fortunate to
learn trading from you know many of the
biggest traders in the world and you
know many of them had written books you
know people traded at tutor John Henry
all the big names you know and not even
including you know the bank traders that
I had access to on a daily basis when I
worked at JP Morgan and commer bank and
basically I I over the years I just you
know I would learn I would tap into
their secrets and methods and take notes
you know and I'd be trading next to them
trading along with them and you know
over the years. I developed my own
trading style by taking the best of what
I thought they had to you know that that
they had to share with me. I tweaked it,
tested it and expanded it and you know I
came up with my own orderflow trading
method which is you know a culmination
of of 20 years from being on the floor
to you know working on the institutional
trading desk. You know this is what made
me being a successful trader for you
know commerce bank cargo JP Morgan. I
traded at those three companies for 15
years combined. So it's not like I I I
was an intern at JP Morgan or Homer
Bank. You this was my career. I was able
very fortunate I was able to retire at
43. How many people can you know are
able to do that? Um you know luckily you
know I I took advantage of the situation
and learned from it
and you know and learned how to trade
and that's the problem that a lot of
people have is is they don't want to
take
and time to learn to trade. I mean, I'll
be honest with you, I deal with a lot of
uh new retail traders and and sometimes,
you know, everybody just wants the the
quick fix. So, you know, just really
quick, what is the order flow trader
software? It runs on Ninja Trader. You
can download it for free at
ninjatrader.com. And, you know, it reads
the volume traded on the bid offer and
puts it into an easy to read volumeprint
chart. What I do with my software is I
take it a step further and I have my own
style of trading program so that users
users can trade the order flow based on
my real life trading experience. So you
know what to look at you I said you're
not out in the dark and you know trying
to figure way around you know an
orderflow chart. you know, I I give you
the training and on my charts, you know,
I mean, I'm not going to get into your,
you know, today's a bit uh, you know,
about three three specific things on
order flow, but you know, this high up
here, you know, gave the perfect sell
signal up
here.
So, you know, what am I really talking
about? you know, the three keys to
Oracle trading that will improve your
trading results that you can use
today. You know, really I kind of
actually like this crystal ball because,
you know, it lets you see what other
people are doing in the market. You
know,
how once you understand overflow, you
can sort of anticipate what's going to
happen next.
If you want to buy, you can work a bid
or you buy the offer. You want to sell,
you work an offer, you sell into a bid.
What causes markets to
move is you know markets will move when
you know people start buying up all the
available offers or they sell all the
available bids and what imbalances do.
Imbalances are the volume traded on the
bid against the offer or you know and
you have a certain percentage and the
volume difference you know tells you if
you have an imbalance. So imbalances
measure the differences between
aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers, you know. So really quick, what
does it look? You know, so you know,
again, like I was talking about, this is
actually a corn and you know, the market
here was 326 and a quarter bid at 326
and a half offer. So it's trading, you
know, back and forth like this. And when
all the trading was said and done at
this price, it was three lots traded up
here, 125 here. So this ratio right this
is what tells you if there's an
imbalance and there is you know three
against 125 standard imbalance is you
know 400% some people use 600% and a one
person that has a thousand on his chart
you know and when you don't have an
imbalance like here 37 against 10 it's
not black it's it's black it's red if
there's a selling imbalance it's blue if
there's a buying imbalance
So the big question is, you know, how do
you make money with imbalances? Uh well,
there's there's three ways. There's
there's actually maybe a couple more,
but you know, the the easy ones to
understand are stack
imbalances, huge imbalances, and
imbalances at highs or lows of of a bar.
Uh specifically, highs, an imbalance at
the high of a down bar or an imbalance
at the low of an up bar. Uh let me give
you some examples what I'm talking
about. So here you have you know this is
crude oil. Here you got a stacked
imbalance right 1 2 3 you know 53
against zero 93 against four 105 against
one. And what happens the market starts
to sell off. Now if you notice in this
next bar right where does the market
pull back to? It pulls right back into
this area where you have the aggressive
selling. Selling continues and the
market moves lower. You know, one of the
beauties of of order flow is that it
tells you you could generally have a
good idea of where a market can pull
back to. And you know, stacked
imbalances is, you know, a perfect
candidate to know where a market should
pull back to. And you know, oftentimes
you see a stacked imbalance and you see
the market pull back right into this
area right below it or just maybe a tick
a tick through it.
Another way you could use imbalances is
is what I call huge imbalances. Okay,
now this time I have this chart. It's
the E- mini chart that puts in a lot of
volume. Okay,
so you know I have this one set, this
particular chart set at a ratio of
1,000. So you don't see very many
imbalances or on the previous chart you
saw, you know, you saw a bunch. This one
is set to
a,000. Actually, it's not set to a,000.
I think it was set to uh 600. But you
know, you have this big imbalance. I'm
sorry. This one is the volume is set to
above 3,000. Not the ratio. This one is
volume. You phrase that. It's huge
imbalances. So, what I'm looking for are
imbalances where the imbalance, you
know, the number is over 3,000. The
volume is over 3,000. And why is that
important? Well, you had an area where
you had aggressive buyers, you know,
lifting, in this case, lifting the offer
because it's it's a buying
imbalance, you know, to the tune of over
3,000 contracts. So you see here, you
know, 648 against
3,85. And why is that important? Well, I
know at this level, you know, there's
strong, you know, there's strong buyers.
You know, there's people happy to buy it
at this level. What is that? 2151. Now,
the next bar comes in and you see, you
know, at this at this level again, you
still see very heavy volume. You know,
okay, it's a price above price, same
price, price below. You know, it's an
area, right? Right? I mean, sometimes,
you know, people get fixated at one
particular price and thinking it has to
be that one price. You know, when you're
dealing with support and resistance
levels, you have to remember their
levels, not one particular price. So,
you can see that this level here is is
holding up, right? Where you have that
huge
imbalance. Okay, here's another one,
right? The market shot up to get up to
this level. This green is the high of
the day, this green line. So, you know,
I like to know where the highs and lows
are of the day. And, you know, you could
have that on your chart. Most charting
software will let you chart it. So, we
get up to the high and I got a huge
selling imbalance. You know, 3,000. So,
it was over
3,000. And you know what happened? That
keys me in knowing I I know right away
that, you know, at this high there's a
lot of selling going on. You know,
there's there's, you know, a seller up
there. I don't know if it's one person.
I don't know if it's, you know, several
people. But, you know, I know that when
we get up here there there's some strong
selling because you have you have this
nice big imbalance and you just see it
just sort of, you know, hangs around,
hangs around. Doesn't necessarily come
off right away. I mean, sure, you can
say it came off two points, but really
what I'm looking for is is a bigger
move. And, you know, you just sort of
hang around. You make a new high by a
tick, make, you know, again, you test
that high, then make another high by a
tick before you finally sell off, you
know. So this is you know this imbalance
right here is is giving you a clue that
hey you know this area is being
defended. Now it doesn't again you know
people always think it has to come down
to that one price. It doesn't you know
because especially in these contracts
nowadays with all the um high frequency
trading going on. Sometimes you see the
market poke through a price level trade
a few lots and then you know make the
make the reverse. Sometimes, you know,
the way the algos are, you know, that
they're testing to see what's up
there. So, you know, this was your clue
that, you know, hey, this this high can
hold. And it gave it to you very early
in the, you know, in that move. You
know, in the first bar up there, you're
seeing that imbalance and you just you
hang around it for the next 20 minutes
before coming
off. Okay. Now the next one I want to
talk about is this one is unique to my
software but actually I think since my
software has come out I think a few
people have have copied it and what it
is is imbalances at high of a bar that
closes down. Okay people you know if
you're watching any orderflow videos you
see people talking about uh trap traders
here trap traders there. They don't
really get into it, but you know, I have
this programmed into my software, and if
it's a red, if it's a down bar with an
imbalance at the top, you're going to
get a red arrow. If it's a buying
imbalance, sorry, a selling imbalance at
the bottom of a green
bar, the bar that trades up, you're
going to get this green
arrow. And you know, why is why do I
consider this trap traders? Well, what
you have, you have the market right here
is trading, you know, 86 40 86 at 4087
and everyone, you know, you have a move
going up, right? All of a sudden, you
got this imbalance right here, 7 against
74. Why isn't the market going up? You
know, people are aggressive. People are
trying to buy it, take it higher, but
there's a strong seller up there. You
you got this
imbalance and then what happens? The
bar, the price action of the bar, we
close lower. Okay? So you're left with
this imbalance at the top of the
bar and that's a very bearish
signal. You know, this is, you know,
honestly, you know, people copy some,
you know, a lot of the things that I do
and and put it in their software. But,
you know, this is something, you know,
if you're just using a normal volume
footprint chart, you could see it
yourself. You know, I like to have the
arrow in there because, you know, it's
it's something to slap me upside the
head. Say, "Hey, idiot, don't miss
this." Because it's a nice shortterm
signal. You know, I'm not looking to
this be the high of the entire day, but
over the next few bars, I'm looking for
it to to go in that
direction because, you know, people say,
well, you know, these guys are trapped.
But, you know, 74 lots isn't really that
trapped and it's really a change in
psychology more than anything else
because there's enough volume in the
markets. You know, even if it was 700
lots that, you know, they have this
imbalance, there's still plenty of
volume to get out over the next bar or
two. Maybe I have a different definition
of of trapped than other traders. Again,
here's another example. You know, this
time it's, you know, at the high of the
day, but it's a buying imbalance at the
high of candle that goes down. You got
that arrow and what happens? The market
market sells
off. You know, just, you know, the
opposite, you know, at the bottom of a
bar that closes up, you got a selling
imbalance this time. So, again, you
know, you're sort of going up, coming
down. got into selling imbalance right
here, but the market can't go any lower.
You know, order flow is telling you
something. You know, it's telling you
that, hey, you know, you had aggressive
sellers here trying to push the market
lower. Chances are you have someone in
there, you know, supporting this in this
supporting the market in this
case. And what happens, you know, market
the turns, market turns around, instead
of going lower, you close higher and you
continue up that over the next uh
several
bars.
Another example, you come up to this
swing high, start coming off. You got
one, two, three, four, five. Five
imbalances in this
bar. Then you come into the next bar,
selling continues and it stops right
here. You know, 78 against 14. And what
happens? Price action in the bar turns
around and it just it continues back up
in that direction. You know, I said, you
know, if you if you had a chart that's,
you know, giving you this information,
it's there and you're not using it, you
know, you're really leaving leaving
money on the table as a as a
trader. Now, another thing, you know, I
I say, you know, it's it's at the low of
a bar, you know, imbalance at the low of
a bar that closes up. Now, doesn't
necessarily have to be the low of the
day, you know, again, you know, people
get fixated, you know, trying to pick
reversals. Sometimes you can only trade
what the market gives you. And sometimes
it's not going to happen right on the
bar where you have the low. Sometimes it
might be on the bar right after it, you
know, or even the third the second bar
after it. But, you know, as a trader,
right, you have to make the decision. Do
you want to take this? You know, if if I
see the market coming down, down down.
Hey, we start to turn around here. I get
this selling imbalance right here. It's
telling me, you know, market came into
the low, rallied off of it, opened up
the next bar, started pushing lower, got
this selling
imbalance, but the price action of the
bar, turned higher, closed higher. You
know, that's telling me, hey, you know,
price is being rejected down here. You
know, I should be looking to get into
this trade, get get long, you know. And
again, it was it was a nice 10 or 15
tick
move. Now, before you know, you go out
and, you know, mortgage the house and
open up a trading account, you know, I
got to tell you, sometimes it doesn't
always work. Um, you know, here's an
example where it failed. Okay, you came
into this low. It's a new low low of the
day. You got that imbalance right at the
low and the market turned up started
going higher but you know it came in and
you know the selling selling came back
you know you made a new low you know
that's why you have to use stops in the
market you know but I I want to show you
that not every trade is going to work. I
mean there's no
100% take it to the bank profitable
trading indicator that you could trade
around all the time. You know, honestly,
if if there was, I'd probably be living
on an island
somewhere. So, what imbalances do is is
they help you make better trading
decisions and better
entries. Okay. So, the next key to order
flow that I I think will help any trader
is delta and understanding what delta
is.
Delta is the difference between
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
in a bar. Again, what is an aggressive
buyer? It's a buyer that buys at the
market. What's an aggressive seller? You
know, it's someone that sells at the
market. Someone that sells into the bid.
Someone that buys from the offer. Why is
that aggressive? Well, imagine, right,
you go to buy a car. You go to the car
dealer. You go there thinking, "I want
to buy this Corvette. I want to pay
50,000." The dealer says, "I want to
sell it at 60,000." But one of you has
to move on their price and the one that
moves on their price is the aggressive
one. So if you know the dealer thinks,
"Oh my gosh, you know, I got a lot of
inventory of Corvettes. I need to sell
this." Fine. He goes down, sells it to
you at your bid price of of
50,000. If you're aggressive, saying,
"Hey, you know, I I need this car to
show off to a to my new girlfriend.
I don't care what the price is. I just
want to buy it." You know, you're
aggressive. You you pay the
offer. And how is it measured? How is
delta measured? Delta is, you know, the
difference between the aggressive buyers
and aggressive sellers. So, what you do
is you take the volume that's traded on
the bid the volume traded on the
offer. So, why is that important? Well,
you know, you're measuring the
difference of aggressiveness in the
market. So, you're either going to have
net aggressive buying or net aggressive
selling.
And does a you know first I got to
explain you know people think you know a
market always moves up
on aggressive buying. Well you can have
aggressive buying late in a bar. You
could have very aggressive selling early
in the bar and you know there could be a
divergence between the delta. It could
be um you know the price could be going
higher but the delta is still negative.
And you know, conversely, if the
market's moving lower, you know, what
people think is the market can is only
going to move lower on strong selling,
not necessarily. You know, they may have
been in a bar very strong buying early.
And what happens is, you know, whoever
that was that was
buying, got their fill, got, you know,
got everything that they needed, you
know, you know, they're they're they're
set on their on their hedge. They don't
need to buy anymore. And then the market
just drops. You know, it's not dropping
on strong selling. it's dropping because
there's no one there supporting the
market. And you know, when a market is
going to sell off from a high or when a
market's going to rally off from the
low, you have two things. You know,
coming from a high, sellers are going to
overwhelm the buyers. Sellers are going
to take control of the market. When the
market's going to rally off the low,
buyers are going to overwhelm sellers.
you know, when you're at the low, you
know, people are working offers for the
market to move. You know, aggressive
buyers are going to have to come in and
start lifting the offers and and take it
higher and higher. And Delta is the key
to picking this up when it's happening.
Um, you know, but it's it's best
explained by by looking at
charts. And so here you have, you know,
crude oil is a one minute chart. And you
know the order flow charts will give you
delta max delta min delta. I'm not going
to get into max and min here, but what's
important is, you know, you have a
market that's going up, right? And you
have, you know, here at this bar, okay,
you got a positive delta 656, you know,
it's strong aggressive buying. Next bar,
you make a new high and the bar after
it, you you hit the same high, but look
at the delta, it's minus
72, you know, and zero even. Okay? and
you you but you got new highs. So you
don't have that strong aggressive buying
that you had earlier, right? If if
you're looking, you know, just really
quick, if you're looking at the order
flow, you can see, you know, as you're
going up, you know, there's it's bid
here is 667
239, you know, traded on the bid. So
there's people selling it at, you know,
into these bids as as you're going
higher. So you know, there's interested
sellers up here. And then what happens?
You break out the high. This is what a
stop kind of looks like when it gets
triggered. In case you're wondering how
it looks on an orderflow, you tend to
see very small numbers on one side and
imbalances on the other. But you pop up
and you make a new high. Okay, very
strong positive delta. You're thinking,
hey, I got very strong delta on the
high. Maybe we should be going higher.
Then what happens in the next
bar? It comes off and the next bar off.
And you start working your way down. And
what's the sign? Well, the sign is the
delta. You got minus
234. Okay, maybe you're not convinced
that, you know, hey, sellers have taken
over. The next part is even a stronger
negative delta and you got a bunch of
imbalances in there. You know, in this
case, you know, sellers have taken over
from the buyers and you know, the move
in the market lower, right? I mean,
you're at the high, you got strong
delta, why aren't you going higher? You
know, if you're going to go higher,
you're expecting to have positive delta.
All of a sudden, you got negative delta
right off the high. You know, the market
is telling you that, hey, you know,
sellers have taken over. You know, this
is the beauty of of order flow is this
information. You don't get this on on a
normal bar
chart. And you know,
this this continuation, right? So, you
can see the negative delta, the previous
chart that I just showed you. This is
the follow through. And you know, it it
came, you know, it was a nice move
lower. you know, you're talking 20 ticks
over, you know, the next 15
minutes. Again, you know, crude oil,
right? This red line is the low of the
day. And what do you got? You got small
deltas 39, 71, 38, 73, 27, 25. You know,
this is people ask and say, "Hey, what
does absorption look like?" You know,
how do you know that, you know, the
market has found a level that it can
trade around that everyone's happy to
trade, right? Markets exist to
facilitate
trade
and delta is going to tell you generally
that you know hey the market's
facilitate facilitating trade by having
small deltas no one's really in control.
You know you got 39 71 38 73 27 25.
These are very small delta numbers.
Often it's the difference of one or two
trades. Now this is a minute chart. You
know maybe if this was a minute and 30
seconds this delta number would be zero
or this delta number would be zero. and
you're just sort of hanging around. You
know, you don't have much price
fluctuation. You're in a very tight
range. Okay, fair enough. You know,
Delta is telling you, hey, you know, the
market's found a level where people are
happy to trade and the market's happy to
facilitate trade. But then you get
towards the end here of this chart and
you see, you know, a nice tick up, you
know, 127, 181. You got two bars with
some strong
delta, you know, together. You know,
here you got 7 177, but here this is a
sign. Hey, you and we're starting to
move higher. 127 181. The delta is
getting more
positive. This is the chart continued.
127 181 276, right? So, you see the the
increase in aggressive buying. You know,
aggressive buyers are are picking it up
right here off the
low. The market goes sideways over the
next 10 minutes.
You know this is you know the
3935 area and you know but the orderflow
is telling you hey you know buyers are
accumulating a position and what happens
over the next you know the next 10
minutes you know we shoot up another
another 10 ticks you know so that's
information you know the delta gives you
nice information that you can make you
know good decisions off of you know
again you know you see this stuff you
know you almost every day happening Um,
you know, sometimes it's not as
beautiful as as some of these charts I'm
showing you, but this is another
example, right? Again, this is crude.
You know, we're going up. You got strong
buying. You know,
2234 1167 in the delta. It's all
aggressive buying. You know, this one is
probably another stop. You got a lot of
zeros here. When you a big stop get
triggered, you see you don't, you know,
it doesn't really come back in right
away. You get zero because the stop is
trigger just listing every offer on the
way up. Other traders jump in, you go
higher, you got strong positive delta.
Then you come here, you're at the new
high 4098. Then what happens? The next
bar, you get negative delta. Okay. Well,
that's a sign that hey, you know, we're
up here at the high. Sort of got
negative delta. You know that that's not
a good sign. You I'm not seeing the
follow
through. This number up here, 5917, is
is a ratio that's unique to my orderflow
trader software. I'm not going to
discuss it, but when you have a ratio
like this in a blue, it's also telling
you that, you know, hey, the market's
poised to to sell
off. But, you know, what I'm talking
about is delta. So, you have your sign
up here, right? And if you want to take
it a step further and analyze these two
bars here, you got 22 34 1167 minus 286.
What do you notice? The buying is
getting less. You know, it's very strong
here. And then it's cut in half. It's
1167. It's half the delta of the
previous bar. And then the next bar
doesn't even go anywhere. It's, you
know, four price levels. It's an inside
bar and you got negative delta. And then
wham, this next bar after it, you know,
it really comes off a very strong
negative delta. you know this if you're
not convinced in this bar and you wait
for this bar to confirm it is still
giving you a decent chance to get in and
then the next bar up here at at 40 uh
you know 4086 4087 4088 you know
somewhere in this early in the bar is
traded enough volume that you can get
in and we sell off you know we sell off
in a nice 15 ticks over the next you
know three or four
minutes you know but really what gave it
away was this delta you you're going up
on on less aggressive buying. You come
off the high and all a sudden sellers
are taking
over, you know, and just, you know,
conversely I'll talk, you know, at the
low, you know, the opposite is true.
Here's a nice move coming in down down
688 negativeus 398 at the low minus
132. In this case, you also have that
selling imbalance that I talked about on
a green bar. You got this green
arrow, you know, which is also a sign by
itself. But what you have is, you know,
you're coming down into the low on less
aggressive selling. I mean, it's sure
it's making new lows and there is net
selling, but it's lesser. It's getting
less. It's I don't say drying up, but
it's getting lesser. And then you turn
around in the next bar and all of a
sudden you got a nice big strong
positive delta. You know, that's a sign
right there. You know, maybe you're not
convinced and you wait for this bar. You
know, this one is is is close. It's
borderline. It spends its time going
sideways. You know, not every time.
After every move, a market is, you know,
going to come down straight and then go
back up straight. Often times,
unfortunately, it does sort of go
sideways. Um, you know, that that that's
trading. You know, we all like to get
the nice move down, buy it off the low,
and for it to go straight back up. But,
you know, if you've been around the
market long enough, you know, a lot of
times you get moves like this, you know,
but it's giving you a low a low risk
entry, you know, in here
because you know that, you know,
aggressive buying is coming in and if
aggressive selling, you could watch the
delta and if it you notice it changing
picking up, you know, strong negative
again, then we might make another run at
the low. Again, to move off the low,
you're going to want to string together
positive deltas. you're not going to
move very far off a low on negative
deltas, you know. So, what is delta? You
know, briefly again, you know, it's
knowing when one side is stronger than
the other during a moment in the trading
session. And, you know, that's very
valuable information uh especially at
highs or lows of the day or you know,
swing highs or swing
lows. So, the last thing that I want to
talk about is point of control.
You know, point of control is is
something
that right now is unique to order flow
trading and you know it came from market
profile. It's the price in a bar where
you have the most volume. You know one
again one of the problems that new
traders face is they treat every price
in a bar the same but every price is not
the same.
Some price levels are going to have
light volume. Some price levels will
have, you know, your average volume. And
there's going to be one level that has
the most volume. Again, that price level
with the most volume is point of
control, also known as point of control,
P. And why is PC important? Well, it's,
you know, it's the PC in a bar, right?
The the price level with the most volume
is the value area of that bar.
Now, you know, step back for a moment.
You know, just talking about trading in
general, right? Markets spend their day
searching for value. You know, they
always they go up, they go down. What
they're looking for, they're looking for
an area where trade can be
facilitated. They're looking for areas
where everybody can trade and be happy.
That's the value area. And why is the
value important is
because that's going to help you define
the support and resistance.
And more importantly, you know, when you
break it down into, you know, individual
bars, it's going to tell you where it's
happening right now in real time. You
know, if you look at a volume profile or
a market profile, you know, that's
spread out during the day. But when
you're looking at individual
bar, your point of control is going to
be your value area for that bar. And how
do you determine what the value? Well,
it's the price level in the bar with the
most volume. And you know, it puts a box
around it. software will put a box
around that area so you can see where it
is. So yeah, you can see here, you know,
you're going lower, right? You have
lower points of controls. You know, on a
market that's going down, you're going
to have lower points of controls. On a
market that's going up, you're going to
have higher points of controls. On a
market that goes sideways, you'll often
have point of controls lining up at the
same price level.
So, you know, it gives you a visual, an
additional visual beyond just, you know,
an open, high, low, close bar or or a
candlestick. You you you have a better
idea of how a trend is moving or how a
market is going
sideways. And you know, again, value
forms where you trade volume, you know.
So, here you can see one, two, three
price levels or one, two, three bars
with the same price level. I know that
you know roughly 2078 is you know that's
an area where people are happy to
trade you know this can be a a
resistance level when we start coming
off from the market from this level
right here we start going lower come
back up I know that this is a level that
people are happy to trade at you know I
would expect more of the
same now when I talk about point of
control as being support or resistance
and you Let me tell you some examples
you know and to me this is you know
again one of the beauties you know
there's a lot of beauties of orderflow
trading but you know imagine right
you're you're walking down the street
you know like I always use the example
of Jack in the bean stock and some guy
pulls you into the alley says you know
hey I got these magic beans you know
what if a you know an old trader came up
to you and said hey son I I could teach
you how to find the support and
resistance in the next bar based on the
bar we're in right now would you be
interested interested. Yeah, of course
you'd be interested. It sounds a bit
creepy though, some guy pulling you into
the corner, but um in what you have
here,
right, your point of control, right, in
this bar, say you got to now you have to
determine, you know, are we in a move or
not? And you know, if I say this is
going to be the low of the move, I I
expect the market to move back up. I
know this is my point of control. I'm
going to look at this point of control
as being the support since I'm expecting
a move up of the next bar. And what
happens? You trade almost right down to
it. You get within a tick of it. Then
you have your new point of control here.
Okay. Again, I'm still bullish. This is
going to be my support level. What
happens? The next bar comes in. We got
one tick through it. Fair enough. That's
not the end of the world. Like I said,
it's support and resistance levels, not
support and resistance price. So, it's
it's fine to get through it by a tick or
two.
It's not the end of the world. And what
happens in the next bar here? You got
your point of control. You trade right
down to it. Rally back up. Then here you
got a red candle. Okay, fair enough. But
you got point of control at the same
level. You know, I'm still looking, you
know, either as you know, these two or
even, you know, this one as as my my
sort of, you know, my my back stop
fence. And what happens this next part?
We trade right down to this point of
control.
Then we got a new point of control here.
We're resuming our move back up. We
trade right down to get through this
point of control by a tick. New point of
control again. You know, one, two side
by side. Now, I'm feeling fairly
confident we're trading above, you know,
these two side by sides now. So, you
know, I I feel that we're put in, you
know, a level here, a fairly strong. And
what happens the next bar? You trade
right down one tick above this point of
control and work back up. So, you can
see how, you know, on on a move up, it's
your support.
You know, this is a five-minute chart
here. You know, the previous chart I
showed you was I don't know what it was.
It was a three range chart. It was very
tight chart, you know, but you know,
five minute chart. Okay, we're going
higher up up. Okay, you know, I've
decided already we're going higher. I'm
looking at the points of control as
being my support. You have your point of
control here. We get down to it by a
tick here. Get down by a tick. Trade 14
lots. Go back up. We got a stack buying
imbalance again, which is also
bullish. You know, we pull back within
the stack. You know, it's one tick above
the stack buying imbalance, but more
importantly, one tick
above the point of control again. You
know, new point of control here, you
trade one tick through it. You trade
eight lots through it. You know, your
point of control here, you know, you
trade within one tick through it. Okay,
you get up here again. You trade right
to this point of
control. Okay, you get to the the high,
you know, things start to change a
little bit. You got a red bar. Okay,
fair enough. You your point of control
is here. You know, like I say, you know,
support and resistance. You know, your
support often can turn into resistance
on a move down. What's important is, you
know, it's here. And notice these next
three bars, they all trade right up into
that area. You know, you got negative
delta. You got some nice imbalances up
there. You know, it really looks like,
you know, a market that, you know, at
this point, I I would say this move is
over. We're staying below this previous
point of control. You got some nice
selling in balances in there. The market
looks like it's ready to come off. I I
should have put the the next chart, but
again, I just want to show you how how
it
works. Again, another fiveminute chart,
you know, off the low. You have your low
here. Um, you know, these are delta
candles. It's the new indicator we came
up with. But um so if it's positive, it
tells you delta is positive. If it's
sorry, if it's green, it tells you delta
is positive. If it's red, tell you delta
is
negative. So we come into a low negative
delta. Okay, we're hanging around, but I
see delta getting positive here. So I'm
thinking, hey, you know, we might start
to move off this low. Okay, I got a
green bar. You know, that's my first
sign that hey, price action is changing,
you know, and off this low. I got these
nice balances, buying imbalances. 2,00
2,000. So, this bar is going to be the
key. And what do we do? We rally, you
know, we rally the next bar. You come
right down to that point of control, new
point of control. You get right down to
it. Tick through it here. A tick
through, you know, and you just keep
going up, right? You got your higher
points of controls as the market starts
to move
up. Okay, this is the third example.
again, you know, you're at your low and
you're looking for, you know, hey, is
this market going to go up? Well, yeah,
you have higher point of controls here,
but really it's all sort of about the
same level. You know, you got two here
at the same level, one, two, three at
the same level, these two at the same
level. You're looking for a sign that
maybe it
it's going to go higher, right? You're
at a low. You want to have a reason to
buy
ideally, and you're starting to see it
here. You got, you know, you start to
see it here, you know, point of control
pulling in point of control, but then
you got a red bar. Now you got green.
Now you got another green bar, right? So
your point of control right here at 66
and a half, you pull down again right to
that point of control. This next one you
pull right into that point of
control, you know, just to
continue, you know, you got down here
one tick above, right down to the tick,
you know, here, one tick through, traded
eight lots, you know, you trade, you
know, right to that point of control.
You go sideways again. Again, now you
found a new value area, right? You're
talking about markets, you know, search
for value area. Earlier, this is the
previous chart.
You have this value area where these
points of controls are all around the
same level. You know, people were happy
to trade at that price, you know, but
now price started to move. You found a
new value area right here and the market
pauses, it goes sideways points of
control all sort of at that same area.
You know, this is it on the next, you
know, when when you scroll forward, then
what happens? you continue your move
back
up, you know, but you know, again, you
know, if you can determine that, you
know, hey, that's going to be the low
earlier, you know, look at the point of
control. It's going to give you that
entry, you know, the area where you can
get in around fairly safe and have a
tight stop, you know, not too far from
it, you know. So, again, you know, what
does point of control do? I think it
gives you a solution to the problem that
many tra traders have is, you know, one,
how do you determine how if a market's
going up or going down, you know, if
you're having higher points of
control on a move up, chances are the
market's going to go higher. If you have
lower points of controls as the market's
going down, then it's fairly safe to say
you have, you know, a move lower. And if
you got points of controls going, you
know, lining up going sideways over
several bars, chances are the market's
going
sideways. And one of the added benefits
is, you know, it gives you levels in the
market that you could hide behind with
your stops. So you don't have to have,
you know, an arbitrary stop that's so
far away. You could hide behind a point
of control from one or two bars before
that, you know, if you get through
there, it's a warning sign that, hey,
you know, maybe this this trade is not
going to work out.
So,
you know, if there's one piece of advice
I give you, stop doing what doesn't
work. You know, I I said, you know,
since I started up my company, order
flows, I've dealt with a lot of traders
that keep doing the same thing over and
over and they wonder why it's not
working. Well, it probably because, you
know, they can't make it work or it
doesn't work. It's flawed.